-Finally, guys, it's Monday, and I think we all could use
a little encouragement to make it through
the rest of the week. Don't you feel that way?
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's time for some "Monday Motivations."
Here we go.
♪♪
You look amazing in that shirt.
Trust me. You're gonna have the best week.
When you go to the zoo, everyone's like,
"Wow. What a beautiful specimen."
And they're not talking about the animals.
On day one of planning her world tour,
Beyoncé sat down and was like, "So where does Abby live?"
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
When you agree to see a dessert menu,
the waiter is like, "Yay. You're staying."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
You can feel this one?
The day you got your braces off, your orthodontist was like,
"Oh, God. What if I never see her again?"
[ Applause ]
When you get pit stains, everyone's like,
"A shirt with polka dots in the armpits? I love that."
[ Laughter and applause ]
When you click "book flight" online,
the President of Costa Rica is like,
"O-M-G, guys! Emily's coming! Emily's coming!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, when your phone dies, it's like,
"My one regret is not spending more time with you."